[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
someone order a truckload of rakes for
the Republicans are running out hurry
we don't want them to run out of race to
Stefan
oh man if you're not happy this morning
in the pro-democracy Coalition you're
not doing this correctly you're just not
doing it correctly the Republicans are
absolutely [__] pissed I mean they're
mad
that speaker Hakeem Jeffries in the
Democratic caucus passed the debt
ceiling Bill
[Laughter]
oh my God what a bunch of [__] idiots
listen Hey Kevin you know if you would
have just a couple weeks ago not been
such a dumb [__] and just did what
President Biden told you to do he said
it out loud he said look just send me a
[__] a clean debt ceiling bill and
I'll negotiate with you on the budget
and I won't make a fool out of you and
Kevin McCarthy couldn't help but step
directly on that rake and face plant
right into it
folks Joe Biden can't be feeble and Ill
minded and
dementia ridden and the school these
[__] like this all at the same
time not not those two things are
different
and that's what the Republicans are
saying this morning they were
outmaneuvered
by the feeble old dementia ridden Joe
Biden who can't find his own socks and
shoes
what does that say about them
well it says more
about the Democrats
and how serious they are about policy
and the process of policy listen I've
been telling you this for a long time
these people are not [__] serious
they don't have serious staffers they
don't have people who are serious about
fixing the country for America they
don't they're not they won't be
it's not a thing that will happen these
people are running around with genitalia
brain focusing on wokism as if it's a
[__] thing
complete completely completely obsessed
with chant transgendering gay people as
we start pride month you're gonna watch
their [__] heads explode every 10
minutes
they're not going to be able to buy
anything go anywhere have any kind of
entertainment or Recreation it's all
going to be stripped away from them by
themselves
because they gotta boycott everything in
sight
because anything with a rainbow on it is
somehow related to their [__]
sensitivity that someone else wants to
be who they want to be love who they
want to love it's a you problem
[__] and that's why Kevin
McCarthy lost
they're so [__] so [__] deep
in the ass of fascism at this point with
their head that they can't see the light
of day and you know to be quite honest a
lot of people are gonna blame this on
Kevin McCarthy and Marjorie Taylor green
and there's gonna be a lot of blame to
go around that they're going to be
pointing the fingers at there's only one
[__] to blame for this it's
Donald Trump Donald Trump wanted this he
wanted this stupid fight he wanted the
[__] debt ceiling to pop he wanted
the economy to crash
this is what he wanted and he wanted
Kevin McCarthy to take it all the way to
the [__] Brink
and because they listened to him Joe
Biden and the Democrats schooled their
asses rolled them up and smoked them
like a Philly joint
it's not complicated to understand or no
when you're not serious about policy
when you're not serious about governing
you will get your ass kicked in a
negotiation especially over something
like the debt simple as the debt ceiling
with someone who has been in government
their entire [__] adult life and
understands every single lever and every
single mechanism of our Congress you
stupid [__]
what did you think was gonna happen
honestly the Republicans should be
wishing that they lost in 2022 the
majority in the house
they because this this does not bode
well for them
this was their last [__] chip that
they could play
at this point Joe Biden is totally
[__] crushed that on them
what other chip are they gonna play here
and it
and the Democrats and Hakeem Jeffries
passed it
with the help of
Donald Trump Kevin McCarthy and Marjorie
Taylor green
holy actual [__] these people are dumber
than dog [__] and listen this morning
after watching this
and going over it and and seeing exactly
how
they absolutely
self-destruct every [__] time
honestly I keep saying that we want
smarter Republicans but do we do we
really
do we want Republicans that are smarter
than this I mean honestly don't you see
how easy it's going to be if we as the
pro to pro-democracy Coalition engage in
our democracy and take back super
majorities in these red States get them
get rid of Republican super majorities
take back the house increase the Senate
hold the line with the presidential
election get it King Jeffries to
actually hold the power of speaker of
the house not just do the job
which he did the job yesterday
don't you see don't you see how easy it
will be to set policy that's smart
that's easy
that's clear to see that helps the
American people it's going to be really
[__] easy with these boneheads
I there's a senator from [__]
Oklahoma what what what the hell is his
name mark Wayne he's got two first names
combined together as a first name I mean
I got two first names but Jesus Christ
you combine them and you don't put a
space or a hyphen Mark Wayne okay
Mark Wayne he gets his ass handed to him
in a Committee hearing they [__]
laugh out loud at him
this is a sitting United States Senator
who walked straight into dumb [__]
and it's all because of their [__]
little p brains have woke mind virus
they keep saying we have the woke mind
virus what the [__] are you talking
about you people can't stop talking
about wokism you can't stop boycotting
every [__] rainbow everywhere time
out we have a mind virus you people are
delusional [__] out of here you have the
woke mind virus clearly it's projection
when you say that [__]
but let them keep going [__] it why why
would we stand in their way of of
absolutely self-destructing
don't get in their way let them do it
don't take the shovel out of their hand
when they're digging their political
grave
[__] get him a backhoe get him a goddamn
backhoe let's speed up the process why
not
why not because they're gonna nominate a
[__] criminal a [__] treasonous
piece of [__]
who's probably gonna get charged with
his [__] espionage
there's tapes oh my God so you thought
the debt ceiling is big news oh they're
the Cheeto desk q and honors caught on
tape talking about how he's got
classified documents for plans to attack
Iran
and somehow somehow I don't know how he
has these documents and then Jared
Kushner gets two billion dollars from
Saudis and Donald Trump gets a a golf
tournament at his golf courses I wonder
how all that happened how could that
have possibly been
point A to point B huh I don't get it
oh and there's tapes there's [__]
tapes of him saying
that he knows these [__] plans are
classified which absolutely destroys the
argument that they've been making this
entire time that he Declassified him
before he left the White House and he
did it with his mind
his mind I did with my mind
and all the while this morning
the same [__] criminal is destroying
the [__] Florida Governor absolutely
destroying rightfully so Ron dude you
[__] suck at this man listen what you
should do Ron what you should do is just
go home to Florida and stop talking stop
shaking people's hands stop getting in
front of people it's awkward as [__]
it's doing the opposite of winning you
an election man
the exact opposite
he can't even attack Donald Trump by
name it's [__] ridiculous
listen
if this was a real [__] race
if this was a real race and they were
really trying to beat Donald Trump and
trying to attract the Republican
Coalition back behind them they would be
calling him a [__] criminal and they
would be calling him a treasonous piece
as [__] they would be [__] digging on
him every chance they get and not this
light-handed [__] like oh we need to win
we don't need losing policies anymore we
need to go all in on wokism
okay yeah good luck with that keep going
keep going don't stop
you're going to [__] lose with him or
with you
you think Rhonda santis is gonna win
over the American people
wait till I show you this clip where
he's in like a [__] Diner or
something and a reporter asked him why
he's not taking questions from his
supporters and he loses his ever loving
[__] mind just loses his mind on this
reporter why are you blind are you blind
haha
done bode well
Ronnie dude you're done you're kids it's
over man it's over you might as well not
even finish through this the first two
primaries you're not gonna win delegates
I mean here's the thing Ron DeSantis
isn't going to win a single [__]
delegate probably and then when Donald
Trump gets up on the stage on the
Republican National Convention next
summer he's gonna say that [__] out loud
he's gonna he's gonna [__] destroy
you on stage after he wins on the first
[__] ballot
you people are a bunch of dumb
[__] man I'm telling you I'm
telling you if you if you think that
having Ron Ron DeSantis D santis Mike
Pence Chris Christie Tim Scott
Nikki Haley Asha Hutchinson if you think
all these people getting in this race is
gonna be good for you you are a bunch of
dumbasses this is bad for you it's good
for Trump the more candidates the better
for him
he's not gonna lose his cult he's not
he's not going to lose his cult so stop
trying to attract them
I'm trying to give you some advice on
what a winning strategy would be here
they're not gonna [__] listen to me
why would they listen to me [__] the
Democrats don't even listen to me at the
time I mean sometimes I feel like they
do sometimes I feel like they do
right they're listening in they're like
ah this guy's [__] crazy but he's
right
maybe they'll [__] start listening
some more to what the hell I'm saying
but Republicans definitely aren't going
to listen but here's some advice for
them if they would like to take it my
advice to you is to dump Trump dump
DeSantis dump the wokism transgender
people [__] you stupid [__] walk away
from bigotry now right now
right now
do you do you know how much much less
ammunition we're gonna have to
politicize if you would walk away from
those [__] things they're not going
to they can't they can't they're in they
they've they've bred their entire
[__] base to be used every ounce of
hate they have
every single [__] last ounce of hate
that their base has they encourage them
to use it that's the design of their
machine and that's why they keep losing
and that's why they're gonna continue to
lose
it's not gonna get better for them it's
only gonna get worse because we are
going to band together as a
pro-democracy coalition because folks I
think the one thing that's clear in this
country
does it matter what your affiliation is
I don't care what you call yourself what
you think you are politically even if
you don't know because most people don't
even know what their ideology is they
don't know where it's at on the Spectrum
that's how ridiculously uneducated
people aren't about politics in this
country but that's fine whatever that's
just the way it is that's a reality we
have to live in I can't change it you
can't change it overnight it's not gonna
happen that way so we got to live in the
reality that we are right
even those people are like what the [__]
why the [__] can't I go shopping
anywhere without people saying I'm
supporting gay people and what's wrong
with supporting gay people loving who
they want to love that's literally
that's gonna be the sentiment
doubt me [__] you just [__] doubt me
just do it try it
that's gonna be the sentiment why in the
[__]
am I constantly being told that I can't
shop somewhere because they support gays
when who cares if they do I that's fine
whatever they want to do I just want to
go to [__] Target get a [__] choke
a mache Lotto whatever the hell it is
it's Starbucks
and buy some tennis shoes or whatever
the hell you're getting at Target
and then I want to be able to drink Bud
Light if that's what's in the cooler
the [__] are you people talking about
rainbows
they're sick of it America's sick of it
and they're gonna get even more sick of
it because there's no end in sight for
these stupid [__] they think this is
their winning argument they think this
is what they're gonna win on just like
they thought in 2022 they overturned Roe
v Wade and then they go balls deep into
making sure they ban Women's Health Care
and they're like yeah that'll create a
red wave
have that [__] work out for you huh
keep going
[__] let's like I said let's order
truckloads of rakes for these
[__]
let's keep encouraging to step on them
honestly again I was thinking this
morning like man maybe the whole idea of
having reasonable Republicans reasonable
serious [__] Republican politicians
isn't such a great idea
I mean this
this band of boneheads that we have
these nincompoop Nazis that are running
around
in government posing as Republicans
I gotta tell you when they're standing
around punching each other in the
[__] face when a bunch of Nazis are
standing around punching each other in
the face you stand back and let them do
it
and that's all they're doing I mean
sometimes they're punching themselves in
the face and then they're punching other
Nazis in the face listen I'm not against
punching Nazis but the one thing I
definitely not going to do is stop Nazis
from punching other Nazis hell to the no
so let's do that
whoosh there's a lot of news this
morning too apparently um
uh another rake oh Jesus
so the document that Chuck Grassley goes
on Fox news this morning this document
that Jim Comer has Jim Comer the Cuban
honor what a [__] idiot how the [__]
is he the God damn
chairman of the oversight committee
they're wanting this FBA document that
was given to the FBI by Rudy Giuliani
yeah that's right grandpa farty mcshardy
Rudy colludi that's who they're gonna
trust with this document Chuck Grassley
goes on Fox news this morning it's like
yeah yeah I've seen the document and
basically it's all a bunch of [__] but
I'm here to tell you that we're gonna
politicize this okay Senator Grassley
that's the best they got that listen
listen to me folks
Jack grantly Senator
979 years old from Iowa
is the best they got to go on Fox news
this morning to tout this [__]
document that is all [__] it's all
made up it's all just fake ass
accusations that Rudy Giuliani planted
into the FBI's hands
and they think this is going to be a
great [__] Revelation and the
country's gonna oh my God we need to get
rid of Biden because Rudy Giuliani gave
a fake [__] document with fake
accusations to the FBI and Jim Comer got
a hold of it and Chuck grassley's looked
at it and says well it's not really
going to hurt Joe Biden politically and
it really I mean it's just about Jack
Jason saying true and really we're not
even we're not even really trying to
figure out if it's true
he [__] said that [__] I'm gonna show
you I'm gonna show you the rake they're
stepping on this morning it's hilarious
it's great you should laugh you should
have fun yeah you got to be outraged you
gotta point in in a certain direction
right we got to politicize this [__]
we have to make sure we mock the ever
loving [__] out of them trust me the
country's getting wise to this stuff
they're getting wise to this stuff
because because there's pushback from us
about stupid [__]
like Disney
and Bud Light and Target and Kohl's and
there's rainbows everywhere
this is not gonna play well it's not
it's just not going to [__] work and
that's great let them keep going their
their loss is our gain for democracy
good [__] them
oh boy
[Music]
I'm loving
what else is in the I mean there's just
so much [__] oh yeah by the way Elon
Musk is um
Elon Musk is censoring uh what was a
woman Matt Walsh's movie what was a
woman they're really pissed off about
that this morning oh
they're censoring us some free speech
remember when remember when they loved
Elon Musk you remember that oh man those
are the days like last week when they
thought he was the swells the swell the
swell remember that
do you remember oh man it was so great
and then he hired what they see as an um
awoke CEO this morning oh man they're
really mad they're really mad that they
don't get what was a woman trending
on the very first day of pride month
because it's full of hateful speech
because that's basically what it is is
hate speech and I I gotta say listen
Matt I'm talking to Matt Walsh here Matt
listen man
if if you
would just figure out what a woman is
this wouldn't continue to upset you you
wouldn't continue to have these failures
okay so if you're listening Matt
well let me tell you what a woman is
okay let me tell you I know you've been
running around the world trying to
figure this out for yourself
I I know it's confusing for you
and you know a simple dictionary would
fix these problems it really would and
and really any kind of just I don't know
normal non-fascist thought would fix it
too I think you would have an easier
time figuring out what a woman is if you
would just pluck your head out of your
fascist ass
and and just I don't know use logic and
thinking maybe do a little bit of
reading you don't have to do a lot
but I'm gonna make it easy on you I'm
gonna tell you exactly the answer to
your question what is a woman what a
woman is is it's a gender that someone
identifies as that's what it is
so start there man start there I know
it's tough I know you don't like to hear
those sort of things because it's not as
finite as your fascist ass would like it
and really when you start with that
definition it really is hard for you to
really demonize and dehumanize people
uh with your [__] stupid Nazi
rhetoric when you're using old Nazi
tactics to attack the transgender
community and then you perpetuate it to
gay people and then it's women and then
it's anyone who who's an ally of women
and lgbtq and then it's and oh people of
color oh man oh man and then allies are
people of color and then it's just
anyone who isn't you I get it I get the
whole Nazi tactic thing I get it but man
just start with the simple definition of
what a woman is and you wouldn't have
this trouble you wouldn't even have to
tweet as much think about it man think
about it Matt if you really honestly
came to terms with what a woman is and
what the definition is you wouldn't even
have to tweet that much you would have
so much more free time not thinking
about other people's genitalia not
thinking about what you want other
people's genitalia to be or how they
want to call themselves or identify man
you've had so much more [__] free
time think about how many times you
could read and reread
probably your signed copy of mineconf
just think about how much time you would
have on your hands
to study that book man if you would just
you know start there with that
definition
[__] Matt Walsh [__] the daily wire
happy [__] pride month you sons of
[__] be proud be an ally
be proud that you're an ally and and
welcome them with open arms no matter
who they are or who they love [__] [__]
the daily wire [__] these fascists and
[__] these Nazis
show them what we got and what we got is
we can spread the love around that's
what we can do and it's really easy you
don't even you don't have to do weird
stuff
you just gotta push back on the hate you
can't tolerate the intolerance that's
what that's that's the most important
thing that's the most important love you
can show
I'm serious that's the most important
love you can show is do not tolerate
their [__] intolerance make them
uncomfortable make them defend it in
front of you
make them defend their Nazi tactics do
it
it'll make a huge difference not just in
your life but I don't know everyone
they're trying to eradicate from society
so let's do that on pride month happy
pride month and I I believe
here really soon we're gonna have a an
announcement yesterday someone in the
chat I don't remember who it was and
then we had several other comments after
that
they wanted Pride [__] a merch
that's right and Gabe Sanchez has
delivered on this and I'm gonna show it
to you
here in just a little bit but first I
got to take care of some business why
don't you subscribe here on YouTube
since you're watching right now on
YouTube hit the Subscribe button don't
forget
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
on YouTube where we broadcast every
single weekday live
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific also
you can watch on Facebook if you still
have a Facebook account if you're still
trolling manga over there on Facebook go
to at the Tony Michaels that's at the
Tony Michaels on Facebook you can watch
us live over there every single day
and I want to thank everyone on Twitch
the twitch family is growing over there
we got a great chat here on YouTube
great chat on Facebook and a great chat
on Twitch and it's growing and growing
and growing
so thank you for everyone following us
on Twitch it's free to follow us on
Twitch you just go to twitch.tv Tony
Michaels that's twitch.tv slash the Tony
Michaels if you want to give us a little
extra support and not cost you a single
extra nickel for you prime Amazon Prime
users listen up all you got to do is
link your Amazon Prime account to your
Twitch account and you give us the one
free subscription on Amazon gaming or
twitch that you get with your Prime
account
all the directions are right on our on
on our website the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com you just go
down and click link Amazon and twitch
all the directions are right there on
how to do it and how to give us the
subscription and we get a couple extra
dollars each and every month also
download every single episode because
that's free that didn't cost you a
single nickel to go download it on every
directory if you want that would help us
out any director your favorite directory
Apple Spotify Google
there's so many directories out there
that we publish on and you can download
I want to tell you thank you to the
audience for all the for all
the purchases of the let Demi rake merch
you can get it at
store.btonymichaels.com that's
store.thetonymichaels.com let them eat
rake coming up soon I'm gonna show it to
you we're gonna have [__] em Pride merch
by request in the chat and then again I
I don't know how many messages we had
but I had several messages and comments
saying yes that's what we want that's
what we want that's what we want
so Gabe Sanchez delivered it this
morning for you so don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
right after this break
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment we're
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome
back to the show
[Music]
the website was not loading like I
wanted
oh boy oh boy how are you
happy June 1st and it's the first day of
pride month
and um it is going to be the first day
that you we continue to piss off
Republicans and let them step on all the
rakes that are out there I'm trying to
get and excuse me if I seem distracted
I'm trying to get this uh this primed
shirt going uh let's see if Gabe Sanchez
is going to join us that way I can get
it going when he's joining us
oh by the way
um it was Laura Lee that um
that suggested the pride merch and then
I had um I had several other people like
that sent some comments saying yes
that's what they yes it's what they
wanted so
um that's what that's what we're gonna
that's what we're gonna do
that's what we're gonna do uh let's see
here Pride yeah is everyone calling it I
don't know Pride tea yeah sure okay
I'm just trying to get it up for you
guys so you guys can see this thing Gabe
sent me the um the design this morning
he made this design
um so I think you guys are gonna like it
let's see
um that's what I want there so we'll see
exactly
um
we'll get it going here
that way you guys can
have some pride merch By Request
20 20 23 yeah okay that works
that looks good bit launch listing all
right here we go I'm gonna show this to
you here real quick
I just launched the listing we'll see if
the uh we'll see if they keep the thing
I'm not kidding sometimes they reject
these things we had um what was the one
oh it's [__] ass [__] I tried to make
[__] ass [__] um merch in this merch
store and they wouldn't let me do it I'm
not kidding you okay here's here's the
um here's the pride shirts uh you can go
to uh actually here I'll put the link uh
copy since this is by request in the
chat I'll put it in all the chats uh
paste boom there's your there's your
your [__] Pride merch uh so we got we
uh I did a blue one a gray one there's
gray and there's black
if you want black and then uh White
so you have to you got your choice of
t-shirts there for [__] em Pride merch
now buy request in the chat so thank you
for the request
um everybody and uh so if you want to
get you uh a [__] Pride shirt go
ahead and go over to and I'll try to get
some more products up I promise but the
t-shirts are the most popular ones to be
quite honest and coffee mugs t-shirts
those are kind of the two ones that are
that are that
that's those are the two
that um people like the most it seems
stickers sort of you know a lot of it
depends on what's on the sticker so but
go get your your pride and Gabe Sanchez
did this design by the way uh so if
you're wondering uh this is Gabe Sanchez
made this um this oh [__] there it is
[__] em logo this uh Pride [__] em logo
um this morning
he worked that up so go get your pride
merch over at store not the Johnny
michaels.com
let me give this uh let's see if I can
paste here we'll give it to there you go
give it to the the moderators there now
they should have it moderators if you it
you should be seeing this link coming
directly to the uh the pride merch also
you can get your let them meet rake
merch so and we appreciate all the
support that you guys give us with merch
um it does help uh keep the lights on
here at the show so we appreciate that
and I like the merch to be quite honest
like
instead of just I mean I mean if you
want to do because YouTube doesn't
monetize us so we can't do super chat
but if you want to do like a super chat
you can go over the Tony michaels.com
there's a tip jar there it's at the very
top you just click the tip jar put it in
what you want and that's a good way to
do like a super chat if you want I I
just don't have the ability on YouTube
because they hate my [__] guts
because I say the f word too much
apparently
um but [__] them what are you gonna do
but um the merch is a good way and I
like it because you guys actually get
something right you you you physically
get something when you buy it and you
give us that monetary support which we
have some more affiliate sponsors coming
um I'm in I'm in talks with people
um so hopefully that will be announcing
soon so I appreciate all the support
from the audience it means so much to us
it truly does
it truly truly does
uh some some people are saying I'm
buffering what I don't I don't know I
don't think so
uh am I it might be um yeah I don't know
uh what I consider pens
like a like a like a lapel pen type
thing or like a writing pen
there's two different ones I'm saying
your pens like pen p-i-n
so like a lapel pin I I don't know if
they have pins in that store so there's
two
there's two different there's two
different stores that I have
there's the merch store which is like
where the t-shirts and stuff are and
then there's the hat store and it's got
some t-shirts in it too
um but the problem is with the hats the
kind that I wear they're Flex fit see it
they're Flex fit
that's the kind I like and this the
other store the merch store doesn't
actually have these hats
uh in their in their inventory
so I gotta use the other hat store so
that's why there's two of them I know it
it's kind of confusing but
I want you guys to have more options
when it comes to the hats so that's why
I do the hat store separately from the
merch store but it's all the same thing
like you know if you buy a hat it
supports the show if you buy a shirt on
the other store shirt and and if you go
to here let me show you this if you go
to um
if you go to the Tony michaels.com
I'll show you this here me Tony since
we're waiting on Gabe Sanchez to get
here
okay here we go so I showed you this the
other day but if you go to the website
here
um again if you go
oh I didn't I didn't replace the
thumbnail but here's the um here's the
top link here this takes you directly to
the most current show well what should
be sometimes I [__] up and don't get it
up there but I try to get it up every
morning before we start the show so so
if you're ever looking for the link of
the show this is one of the places to
find it you just go to the Tony
michaels.com and you click on that link
there if you want to support me on
patreon that's that link there here's
the tip jar I was talking about see it
says tip jar donate now that's like if
you want to do a super chat and then
here's the Amazon uh twitch if you want
to link those to give us support but
here's the uh the merch store this is
the one that has the um
Pride logo in it
um the the one we just put up and then
this is the hat store the [__] them hats
and then here's Gabe Sanchez's merch so
he's got his own merch store if you want
to go check out his merch and then all
the links to like where you can watch
the show uh if you want to follow me on
social media and that sort of thing so
it's all at the Tony michaels.com it's
it's just a link tree is all it is
like literally it just it's just a link
tree uh that I just got it forwarded to
the link tree because it's so easy to
put links up and change them and so fast
so I mean I'll give an example like
let's say
um let's see here you see this do like
this one here see the see the um
the merch stores yeah it's got the dark
Brandon uh art on it watch this we'll
change that and then let's change that
to uh let's change it to the the new
[__] Pride logo let's see there we go
okay we're gonna change it here
maybe oh [__]
uh no it ain't gonna let me it's too big
I'll have to have Gabe redo it
and then we can change it uh let me see
if I can change to something else though
let them meet rake let's do that one uh
there it is Boop
okay save okay upload all right now
watch this
all right so we've got we got that let's
see if I don't know if the cookies will
come into effect here
no there it is see see how it changed is
that change to let the beat rake boom so
it's so easy to change that stuff that's
why I use that site so
and I appreciate all the support you
guys give when you go to the Tony
michaels.com it's super important
whether you're whether you're liking and
sharing links
um whether you share the show link every
day whether you go and you follow us on
social media are you are you drop some
money in the tip jar support us on
patreon link your Amazon to Twitch
account or you buy some merge all the
support is appreciated on the Tony
michaels.com but what is most important
is that you guys come every single
weekday every single weekday from the
very beginning of the show to the very
end we have loyal listeners here and you
are the best audience in the world the
best audience
in the world so without without a doubt
where is Gate Sanchez
uh where's Waldo
let's see he's sending Beyond him fine
that was way more than five minutes ago
I think let's see oh yeah he's he's five
minutes late
okay let's let's go to some video here
um while we're waiting on him because I
got I got we got a ton of stuff to talk
about today like this two hours is gonna
go [__] really fast uh really really
fast let's see if I can find uh let's
see oh yeah Steve Bannon
here's Steve Bannon um and this is
Delicious By the way oh my God
number one Steve Bannon looks like [__]
holy [__] look at this guy he looks like
just [__] and look at this [__] on his
shelf in the back
you what is what in the white jesus is
this
do you really think Steve Bannon
[__] believes in Jesus and is some
kind of Jesus follower let alone white
Jesus
the [__] is this with the crosses and
the [__] back here come on man who the
[__] are you trying to fool get the [__]
out of here and then he's got this thing
back here that's his own quote mind him
maybe that's not so weird it's kind of
weird
I don't know
and here's here's the thing if you see
the Chiron here he's giving you the
numbers to call your senator in your
house rep to try to stop the debt
ceiling deal hey look Bannon hey man hey
dude hey hey
grumpy
it's done dude it's a done deal
it was it was done before it was voted
on
and yesterday you watched this a king
Jeffries made sure that he did the job
of the Speaker of the House
which he should be speaker not Kevin
McCarthy
it's clear that that's the case and
Steve Bannon really he kind of makes
that case here listen to this
because if it had been anything cut at
all
these Democrats would have fought You
Like a Knife Fight one thing about our
enemies
that they are tough their focused and
they're dedicating they're passionate
you goddamn right we are
you [__] a right we are
why
then why do you even try man you know
we're gonna win not only more passionate
about you but we're Tethered to reality
which helps us out I don't know on a
daily
you people can't even muster up enough
people in your caucus to get three brain
cells to rub together
and you think you're gonna beat us you
people are dumb as dog [__]
why do you think there was no Red Wave
in 2022
because because we give a [__] about the
American people we don't give a [__]
about your stupid [__] fake ass
culture wars we don't care about it we
don't give a [__] most of America
doesn't we care about real [__] that
affects Americans like I don't know not
going broke because you get a [__]
medical bill right being able to go to
college and I'd be Tethered to [__]
debt your entire goddamn life
maybe maybe having your children start
school and start their education at
three instead of five maybe that would
help maybe not closing rule [__]
schools and Rural hospitals because you
got you gotta own the libs
maybe maybe just maybe have common sense
gun safety laws so you can go out in
public and be safe not worry about some
[__] manga terrorists mowing you down
with an automatic weapon huh nah yeah
just little things like that simple [__]
that's easy to do if you just
I don't know pluck your head out of your
ass but keep going friend
don't don't stop with the shoveling
let's hear what he says about how smart
Democrats are and how stupid manga is
listen to this
you wouldn't you would never see this
happen under Nancy Pelosi I know you
hate the center of her name but hey you
got to think it through
yeah you goddamn right you would never
see this under Nancy Pelosi right agree
with her or not and I'm I'm not always a
fan of Nancy Pelosi not always
sometimes her style but she's one of the
most effective speakers we've ever had
in in the modern history of speakers
because she's smart [__] she
knows the process she knows it
she knows it's Steve Bannon knows that
she knows it
you [__] boneheads why do you even
try just go back to [__] cheering on
professional wrestling for crying out
loud just go back to your fake ass
professional wrestling and stop acting
like politics is entertainment you
pieces of garbage stop actually you know
what again see this is my thoughts this
morning right I'm thinking Jesus Christ
these people need just [__] give up
and go do something else or really do we
want them to I mean think about how easy
this is gonna be
think about it think about what 2020 for
the prospects of 2024 brings now that
this debt ceiling deal is [__] slam
dunked down their [__] throats and
Joe Biden tricked him into passing a
Democrat bill
with Democrats giving
think about that think about it for a
second think about it
Joe Biden tricked the Republican Party
into having Democrats pass a debt
ceiling bill so they could have the
Democrats pass it in the [__] Senate
so that the Democratic president could
sign it into law so that way they don't
have to have this argument next year
during the election
laying the groundwork for Democrats to
absolutely make Republican Zone all
their fascism every single [__] last
drop of their fascism we're gonna make
them own it and we don't have to have
[__] some sort of negotiation on some
fake ass unconstitutional debt ceiling
we don't have to do it we'd have to do
it
and Steve Bannon knows it Steve Bannon
knows they got played but the best part
is is they don't know this [__] until
after they've been played so [__] them
[__] em let's let's hear what he has to
say about how smart Nancy below this is
this is delicious you'd never see that
they run it with this Iron Fist
into and to promote what they want to
promote damn right
and and this is the surrender party it
surrender is easy Frankie
he's talking about the Republicans there
as the surrender party
he's got to be he can't be talking about
Democrats surrendering what surrendering
to who to you get the [__] out of here
hit the [__] and listen if you if you're
not aware of this either I just want to
point this out because the chat's kind
of ringing up here with Biden 2024 dark
Brandon 2024 Biden listen if you don't
know why he doesn't have to debate
[__] anybody if you're still standing
around wondering why nobody didn't
debating anybody you are a dumb
[__] that's right I'm talking to
you even if you're a daily Watcher and
you love me and you love to hear what I
have to say then listen up listen good
listen real [__] good
if you think that Joe Biden has to
debate anyone at this point you have
lost your [__] mind you've lost your
mind you know how to process works and
you don't know who the incumbent is and
what he's capable of you're
underestimating him
just like the Republicans underestimate
him and you're gonna [__] lose you're
gonna [__] lose if you're in the
pro-democracy Coalition and you're going
oh well why can't he just debate why
can't he do this because they don't do
that
that's not how it works that's how it
hasn't worked oh well but Tony we can
change it why just for him because it it
affects your sensibility you sound like
Maga okay
and you're gonna get played you're gonna
get played hard real [__] hard so
pluck your head out of your ass
and understand this
understand what is at stake our
democracy
and understand what the gift that Joe
Biden has given the pro-democracy
coalition
okay understand the gift that Joe Biden
has just handed us
these Republicans are [__] pissed and
they don't even know what to be pissed
about
because if they really if they were any
kind of [__] smart what they would be
pissed about is how Donald Trump
destroyed the House of Representatives
by putting his [__] his [__]
idiots in charge up there
and him having influence over them
if they would have kept Donald Trump out
of the [__] mix at the House of
Representatives this would have never
happened never this is a Donald Trump
fumble because he was calling the shots
he's the one calling the shots for
[__] Kevin McCarthy and Marjorie
Taylor green
and they were the ones pushing this
through and people are pissed and we
should let them be pissed and we can't
let them stop fighting like we gotta get
them fight fight fight fight fight fight
yeah fight you [__] idiots
let's keep listening ah [__] it I'm done
with Steve Bannon I think it's done I
think I had Clips done
would you like that rant did you like
that one
oh boy
there's gonna be a ton of them I'm
telling you it's going to be delicious
oh let's see what else do we got here
any other clips of these people losing
their minds oh I promised you a clip of
um uh what's his oh yeah this guy Mark
Wayne Mark Wayne Mullen Mullen is that
his name
that's [__] gay this [__] guy here
he is okay here's the they're in a
senate meeting and Bernie Sanders is the
chairman oh yeah I hate all you Bernie
Bros out there did you know Bernie
Sanders is a chairman of a committee
oh burn it down step Bernie this and
burning yourself [__] this he's a
chairman he's not even a Democrat he's a
chairman okay and he takes Mark Wayne
here to task I'm not I'm not I'm saying
I like Bernie Sanders I want Bernie
Sanders to be a chairman stop your
bitching stop your bitching about how
it's unfair to Bernie Sanders and the
Bernie Sanders wing of the party if the
Democrats didn't like Bernie Sanders and
didn't want Bernie Sanders have any
power they wouldn't let him be a [__]
chairman got it get it good
okay so here's Senator Mark Wayne and
and he gets schooled by the panel and
Bernie Sanders to be quite honest now
this guy is a [__] homophobe and a
[__] transphobe and just a straight
bigot he's from Oklahoma he's a
republican it's par for the course okay
but and and this is like a two minute
clip here okay but the ending you got to
watch it all to get the ending because
the ending oh
Mark Wayne [__] throws out the rake
right in front of him and jumps on that
[__] he does oh my God he he he like
goes through the rake closet finds the
biggest [__] rake he can step on
and puts it directly in front of him and
jumps on it watch what would you think
would be better I'll ask her everybody
on the panel which is better to teach
this
that is a story that is made up to teach
our kids three-year-olds who have no
idea what race oh my God it's a story
that's made up have you ever heard of
such a thing oh my God it's a book with
a story in it and it's made up can you
believe that to teach children I don't
know all kinds of [__] all kinds of
ideas teach them things holy [__] it's
like that's what education is when
you're talking about a little children
oh my God okay let's continue
all of a sudden is being taught that
white people said this as a truth
someone pointed me that this being a
truth he's really he's really upset
he's really he you know what this is
this is I know what this is
this guy this guy is obviously obviously
upset that people are saying that white
supremacy is bad and that white
supremacy is the reason why some of our
institutions in this country are [__]
garbage and [__] and needs to be changed
from the ground up and it's a long hard
fight for that to be undone and Mark
Wayne here is really mad really upset
that people are trying to make him feel
guilty and his white fridge is white
male fragility is getting in the way of
logic here but let's continue with this
dumbass that white people developed race
oh Jesus Christ that white people
develop that that all of a sudden that
was our word that we developed it is by
the way I'm Cherokee oh my god oh here
here it comes here I can't be I can't be
racist because
dude if you have to start an argument
about how you're not racist because
you're a [__] racist you're a bigot
that's how it works I'm not racist but
listen I'm I'm Cherokee Native American
so I can't be racist
oh okay yeah sure got it I'm sure about
that
[__] Native American I think we have
experienced a little bit of racism
before in my life oh God get that get
that oh man Mark Wayne here is
experience racism in his life look at
this guy look at this [__] look
at this pasty white ass cracker he's got
he's got enough [__] Cherokee in his
pinky finger that he can say yeah I'm
Native American but this [__]
has experienced [__] racism yeah okay
okay Mark Wayne you [__] you
piece of [__] garbage you
[__] piece of trash what up
oh my God and you're wondering why I
don't want to stop Nazis from standing
around punching themselves in the face
well watch this
Senator so so I ask everybody on the
panel which one is better to teach this
or the Jesus Loves Me lyrics do what do
what so he he's mad wait a second you're
telling me Mark Wayne here Mark Wayne
here who isn't a racist because he's got
a little bit of Native American in him
and he has never experienced raising but
I mean the people who were actually
Native Americans right who look like
Native Americans and we're named Mary
hey experience racing so I get to claim
their racism okay
this motherfucker's telling us that we
can't use a book that's made up
that's fiction to teach children but he
wants to use a song about Jesus
you gotta be [__] kidding me right
you have got to be [__] me that this
is his comparison okay go ahead and go
ahead and jump on that rake there buddy
let's see it I'll start down here just
tell me which one I don't have time but
I'll tell you Senator Mullen is that
what children
um in these early years
important that our classrooms I'm just
asking which one is better uh he really
he really hates it when a smart woman
speaks you notice that you know what's
that about these [__] did you
notice who's sitting next to him too by
the way look at this you this
[__] right here in that Tommy
tuberville
the guy who doesn't know we only have
three branches of government and he
doesn't know what the branches of
government is and at [__] piece of
bile sludge this [__]
tuberville
is preventing veterans from getting
Health Care
because he likes terrorists what
okay let's continue I'm just asking
which one is better let her answer the
question please my question is there's
Bernie
now you hear Bernie Sanders there the
chairman and he's like not [__]
shut the [__] up let her answer you
asked the question let her [__]
answer and he continues to do this [__]
which one is better it's important that
children's identity that's not answering
my question let's not answer my question
and that's that's what creates wrong
Executives
he doesn't like smart women let's move
on now let's see let's see if we can
find a woman who isn't smart and
intelligence school me on this stuff
let's see if one of these other women up
here dummies like I think all women are
but then I I get it smack right in my
face let's see if he steps on another
rake one is better to be taught this
book yeah or the Jesus Loves Me lyrics
Jesus Loves Me lyrics why is he so
focused on the Jesus love me lyrics what
you're gonna find out watch it says
everybody's yep that everybody's skin
doesn't
yeah I think it's important to teach
that all children are seen and valued
for who they are and that's so but when
you teach this don't you
she's like that's what Jesus would do
dummy
I wish you would have said that that's
what Jesus would do you [__] idiot
have you ever read the Jesus Book have
you read that fiction have you read that
[__] yet oh man there's a whole second
half of that book that talks about the
opposite of what you [__]
preach
oh yeah okay what Jesus would do okay I
think that other people are start saying
that white kids are to blame I think
it's importantly what they're going to
teach oh my God exactly what it is I
don't want to be to blame for racism
because I get really guilty with my
right white fragility when people say
the truth and they tell history the way
that it's supposed to be told like truth
and [__] he gets really upset they get
really fragile listen
I I don't feel any white guilt I don't
have any guilt for my skin color I don't
because I woke up one day and realized
that I don't have to have guilt to know
the truth I don't have guilt to to know
someone else's experience I don't have
guilt to [__] use my ears and listen
to other folks when they talk about
their experience and just listen to them
just listen shut the [__] up a bit and
listen to what they're saying and maybe
just maybe your experience is different
than theirs maybe just maybe and that's
all it's saying dummies that's all it's
saying all these educators are saying
this look look here there's different
experiences in this country everyone
experiences this country different
Everyone's an individual
and some people experience racism and
here's why they experience racism
because of the racist ass institutions
in this country this is why we have
these things and it's good to know that
that way we can walk around not with our
heads up our ass like Mark Wayne here
I'm telling you it gets better the
ending is going to be great here
I disagree first it is important that we
teach Jesus and Jesus is what we teach
so which one is better reality is do you
think this is could she answer the
question please there's Bernie again
reality
what the [__] did he just say okay watch
when he gets Ah that's what he can't
handle he can't handle women
you can't do it he's like oh they're way
too [__] smart for me
for the these white women let's go to
the black one that'll be better
he's like yeah I'll definitely School
her listen to what he says about reality
listen he says the quiet part out loud
um first it is important that we teach
Jesus and Jesus is what we teach yeah
do you think think this is could she
answer the question please I don't want
reality I'm asking
he didn't want reality I told you I've
been telling you for [__] years I've
been telling you for years that these
people are untethered from reality I've
been telling you that I'm telling you
they don't want to know what the [__]
truth is they don't want to hear it
because they are racist ass bigots and
it makes them think that you're trying
to make them feel guilty about their
racism and that's a them problem it's
it's a it's a you problem Mark Wayne you
[__] bonehead
and and your little stupid little tirade
about Jesus Loves Me versus this book
because really if you boil it down to
those two things rather you're teaching
children in a Sunday classroom with a
[__] song that says Jesus Loves Me or
or you're teaching them with this book
in a school classroom you're teaching
the same principles dummy
you [__] idiot and that's what she's
trying to say that's what she's trying
to tell you and you're not listening and
the reason why is because just what you
said you don't want reality you don't
want the [__] truth you want lies the
same lies that is propped up white
supremacy in our institutions in our
country for [__] decades and hundreds
of years that's what he wants he wants
to be [__] lied to and he wants his
other white friends to be lied to
why would they want to have to confront
the truth especially when their [__]
beliefs are racist and bigoted and that
doesn't help them at all with their
whiteness
that's the bare [__] truth they don't
want the truth they don't want the
[__] truth and that's why they're
gonna lose
that's why they're gonna lose that's why
they'll keep losing in our democracy
because the Coalition is going to get
bigger and bigger and bigger against
this utter [__] stupidity when a
United States sitting Senator folks
this is a United States Center duly
elected in the state of Oklahoma there's
only two of those [__] in that
state and the other one Lankford ain't
much [__] better than this guy
this is the best they got in Oklahoma to
elect I actually don't believe that
let's listen to this one more [__]
time this is important
this is a [__] clear representation
at the Republican party and watch what
happens when he says this I don't care
about reality listen to the room this is
what the country is doing to them over
and over and this is what we should
continue to do is laugh at them and mock
them about their ridiculous [__]
stupid ass ideas that are not Tethered
to reality
thank you
I disagree
um first it is important that we teach
Jesus and Jesus is what we teach so
which one of the reality is
could you answer the question please I
don't want reality I'm asking the
question which one is better that is
exactly that's exactly what it is
even Tommy tuberville there's like damn
ass even my dumbass knows I wouldn't say
that
you really stepped on a fire you dummy
he stepped in a cow pie there Mark Wayne
what a [__] idiot he should be
laughed at he should be laughed all the
way out of the United States Senate and
shame on you in Oklahoma if you voted
for this [__] and if you're in
Oklahoma right now and you did vote for
this [__] and you want to change
this [__] well get out and support a
[__] Democrat because there ain't a
goddamn Republican that's gonna have any
kind of brains more than Mark Wayne in
Oklahoma it just ain't gonna happen they
have the woke mind virus folks that's
what they got they got the woke mind
virus they can't [__] think anything
else but wokeism
they see rainbows and wokeism [__]
everywhere
we got the woke mind virus oh the woke
mine virus exist you goddamn right it
[__] exists and it's in Mark Wayne
lives deep inside him rent [__] free
inside his head when he can't figure out
that Jesus Loves Me song and this book
are trying to teach the same principles
[__] idiot okay Chuck Grassley you
know another bonehead
another bonehead let's do it
he's on Fox news this morning I told you
about this earlier
um this is about the document uh
apparently that they got about Biden
from the FBI
and we found out yesterday that it's a
document that Rudy Giuliani
slipped to him right yeah okay yeah it's
really credible it's probably written by
Russians no I'm serious it's it's
probably written by Russians I'm serious
and Okay let's listen to Chuck Grassley
on this document and hear how important
it is and how uh groundbreaking it's
gonna be
um with this election and really with
investigation and criminal charges well
I'm sure it's just going to be
devastating for
Joe Biden Hunter Biden and the Democrats
let's listen and we aren't interested in
uh whether or not the accusations
against Vice President Biden are
accurate or not well you do what you
said wait no it's supposed to be the
opposite Grandpa like that you want to
see when you're doing stuff like this
you want to do the opposite
right when you're when you're placing a
political attack on someone you want
what you're going to accuse them of to
some degree to stick like they have some
sort of substance you know like they
tried to do with Tara Reid the Russian
asset who is now defected to Russia
because Mac ants couldn't protect her
anymore I'm not [__] you I'm not kid
I wouldn't [__] you you're my favorite
turd that's what she [__] said she
said that in Russia the reason why she'd
affected affected to Russia is because
Matt gatz wouldn't protect her
I'm serious it's the truth that's what
she said I don't know she actually
talked to maggots I don't know Matt gets
like [__] you lady I have no idea I
don't know the ins and outs or their
[__] phone calls and their personal
meetings I'm just telling you what she
said
that's what she said but Chuck Grassley
here thinks that you have level a
political attack and you don't really
have to uh figure out if you know what
the accusations are have any kind of
Truth to them you know why not well
let's let's hear his explanation of why
this is going to be groundbreaking we're
in responsible for making sure the FBI
does its job and uh that's what we want
to know
you just said you read the document is
that right
yes and what did it say
well I'm not going to characterize it
we're going he doesn't know what it says
and the reason why he can't say what it
says because it doesn't say [__]
it doesn't say [__] it's a [__]
nothing Burger they're making this [__]
up because the document that they're
talking about is [__] made up too
and the plot is slipping away from them
like little by little it's all slipping
away I mean remember when there's
supposed to be Hunter Biden's laptop
right and they're supposed to uncover it
and they were supposed to find Joe Biden
stealing Chinese money somewhere and
getting money from China on the laptop
they couldn't do it and they're like oh
well there's transactions up that [__]
the bed right that [__] the bed so now
what they're gonna do is unload a bunch
of Hunter Biden's dick pics on some
website somewhere I'm not getting you
and this is what they're gonna do their
plan is to unload
dick pics a [__] Hunter Biden on a
website somewhere so you can sift
through his dick pics
what the [__] are you kidding me that's
that's the plan
oh okay all right yeah because you know
a lot of people are gonna go
do that
and try to get
um what
oh man you people really are weird you
are obsessed obsessed with genitalia
specifically Hunter bidens for some
[__] reason okay so the story of um
Jack Smith continues and apparently he
has an audio recording from 2021 the
summer of 2021 and you think back to the
summer of 2021 you're like wait what
happened then see they were looking for
um uh documents Nora was like Hey we're
missing a shitload of classifying
documents and we think the [__]
former president has them and we're
gonna request we get these documents
these classified documents back some of
those documents had to do with
secret classified attack plans on Iran
right that's apparently what they're
saying
now
there's a [__] recording of trump
Grandpa Poopypants the Cheeto dust Cuban
honor admitting
that he knows they're classified and he
knows
that he he has to he can't do certain
things with him and he can't declassify
him and [__] there's audio tape of it
him talking
you can imagine
him yapping his trap about this bragging
probably who know I don't do they know
or recorded I don't think they know who
recorded it at this point
and I don't know if it's a phone call or
if it's just like in a room somewhere
listen if you remember remember way back
when he was really [__] worried that
people were wearing wires do you
remember that
do you remember that when there was a
report about people wearing wires around
him
yeah oh boy I mean would you want to be
in a room or a phone call with this
[__] without recording what he
says
come on
yeah some people are saying his own
lawyers I mean that that wouldn't
surprise me if the lawyers like [__]
this guy man I'm gonna record every
[__] thing this guy says this guy is
full of [__] he's a goddamn criminal I
can't believe I have to [__] I can't
believe I have to [__] defend this
guy but that's what you got to do
sometimes when you're an attorney you've
got to defend a criminal like that's
that's your constitutional Duty that's
actually the oath you take because you
know as much as we want to bash
criminals in this country they deserve a
defense an actual defense and I wish
that Donald Trump actually had a defense
to be quite honest but he doesn't these
lawyers are [__] just the good ones
[__] run away from him because
they're like you're [__] out of your
mind
you're Adam I can't take this case no
number one you're not gonna pay me
number two even if you do pay me you're
gonna Yap your trap and destroy my case
the entire time it's [__] stupid
that's the way it is
so that's what's Happening Here is uh
here's Jake Tapper
um with the report here I don't like CNN
but we'll play this clip news a new
piece of evidence that undercuts Donald
Trump's defense in the classified
documents investigation sources telling
CNN Federal prosecutors have obtained an
audio recording in that news or that no
that uh that music a little obnoxious
all the way through the breaking news
do they always do this on CNN I don't
watch this [__]
I'm just asking did dig Did Gabe ditches
ah no he got busy he had he had to do
something so
um
he got busy with something he might come
on he may come up we still got like 45
minutes left I can hold the fort down
[__] I can do this for four hours no
problem
I know you guys want me to but do they
usually play this kind of [__] music
all the way through the breaking news
story or they just play the the and the
front because it feels like this this
music goes on for a while I'll be summer
excuse me oh God damn Jake dude Jesus
mute your mic don't they have a mute
button
is [__]
sneezes into his microphone I mean I
cough into my microphone every once in a
while but I got a mute button you know
so if I gotta sneeze I do this
and then I'm back on see I can mute it
you just push the [__] button but you
know maybe you can get a maybe he ain't
got a button someone's saying it says
they do Hunter here on YouTube says they
do play this music through breaking it's
a little obnoxious it ain't no wonder
people don't watch this [__]
I don't know let's keep watching
president acknowledges he held on to a
classified Pentagon document about a
potential attack against Iran the
recording indicates that not only did
Donald Trump know he had classified
materials in his possession after he had
left the White House but that Trump also
seemed to know there were limits on what
and how he could declassify records
since he was no longer president
okay do you get tired of the media
delivering news like this I don't know I
can't watch the rest of this [__]
click because this chucklehead
yeah who who watches this [__]
are you kidding me you people like to
watch this idiot
are you [__] I don't care if he's a
leftist or he's mainstream media you're
boring as [__]
what the [__] are you [__] me this
is their star
Jake Tapper is CNN star
ah they got rid of Don Lemon which he
was [__] too I don't care people can
[__] judge me and then you get all up
in my grill on that Don lemon's [__]
hack and Don Lemon was horrible
yeah [__] out of here and his name's
lemon
I mean there's some on MSNBC that I'm
like this is what the [__] I I listen
sometimes to Morning Joe
and Joe's all right Mika's all right
Willie's and you know
but sometimes like God damn you [__]
people are boring as [__]
it's some [__] personality get some
character would you please Jesus Christ
be authentic quit [__] quit [__]
acting like you're in a play or
something
yeah I mean yeah you're reading a
goddamn script see that's the other
problem that I have with these the media
is I gotta read this script all the time
yeah okay you know yeah the teleprompter
and that sort of [__] and I guess it's a
good skill to have if you don't know
just how to talk
but that's the thing is I I come here
and I do this two hours every [__]
day I don't I don't do have long scripts
I don't have a [__] list of [__] I
don't have like a prep list or anything
I literally don't make notes to make
sure I don't forget anything
all right I I say this line oh man gotta
say this line yeah boy I mean if I'm
gonna stay in line you know I'm gonna
[__] say it
what the [__] is it with it no wonder
people don't like these [__]
anymore
and ain't no wonder the right it's so
easy for the right to make and mock mock
and make fun of the media and it works
it ain't no wonder I'm just saying yeah
I mean you don't you don't have to like
me because of it
I mean you know Jake Tapper he's just a
personality and is he a journalist yeah
sure to some extent but he's not the
beat journalist that's that's getting
all the facts coming up with these
stories
fight finding the substance of the
stories that feed to him on the
teleprompter
you kidding me
I don't know maybe I'm [__] wrong
maybe I just don't watch CNN enough
maybe it's because the [__] Clips are
[__]
boy oh boy
and you're gonna have your favorites
right like you're gonna have your
favorites that you like to watch
out there you know whether it's on CNN
or
MSNBC or whatever I mean if you're on
YouTube you're watching us the Midas
Network
uh you know
tyt oh God how do you do it how the [__]
do you do it
oh boy okay and let's see um uh oh
did you hear that the fly on Mike
Pence's head is going to run for
President yesterday we talked about
Chris Christie running for president
was it yesterday or day before
ah [__] it's time's running away from
hang on hang on let me go to my notes oh
yeah it was yesterday it was yesterday
we talked about Chris Christie
Christie's gonna he's gonna announce on
Tuesday that he's running
in New Hampshire New Hampshire
well Mike Pence apparently is going to
launch his 2024 presidential campaign in
Iowa
you know
it's almost like yesterday I said on the
show I I'm starting to recall it now I'm
starting to refresh my memory I said
that if you're going to start a campaign
in a Republican primary you probably
wouldn't want to do it on Twitter with
Elon the place that you would probably
want to do it is either New Hampshire or
Iowa hmm
seems kind of funny
it's the Pence Camp listening to me are
they just you know doing the [__] that
you would do I don't know makes kind of
sense to me but uh vice president Mike
Pence the former vice president plans to
launch his uh 2024 presidential campaign
in Iowa on June 7th
next is that next Wednesday
I think yeah next Wednesday
so the day after Chris Christie
which I mean no one's more excited than
Donald Trump to see
the fly uh on Mike Pence's head get in
this race I mean the fly has a better
chance than Mike Pence let's be frank
right really the bike Pence you're
really gonna launch a presidential
campaign for what
why no one [__] likes you
people who hate Trump [__] hate you
people who love Trump [__] hate you
what what who who is gonna vote for you
who do you plan to court
like who do you even plan to go into a
diner and talk to I mean half the people
in there can't stand your [__] guts
and the other half want to hang you
on the capitol steps for not overturning
the government making Donald Trump the
dictator and King of the United States
of America
you get that right dude read the [__]
room and you know what hey more power to
him maybe maybe if he gets the fly out
front it's like the presidential ticket
is fly on Mike Pence's head and Mike
Pence right Mike Pence is the vice
presidential ticket on the ticket the
fly and then him I mean maybe you'll get
a few boats maybe he'll pull out some
votes in Iowa my guess is is that the
straw poll will come out in Iowa before
the Iowa caucus
and that Mike Pence will be like in last
place
and he won't even he won't even go after
that right that's why he's announcing in
Iowa he's announcing in Iowa because the
only chance he's got is to come in the
top five
in the caucus that's it
that's it that's your only [__] shot
Mike and if he can't even if he if he
comes in last place which is likely
I mean
it's my pants it's likely that he'll
come in last place
and I I get the I get the idea
that these [__] are trying to
trying to sneak away the Evangelical
vote from Trump is what they're trying
to do
and they're just they're just not going
to have any luck but we've got luck on
our side because
he's finally here
um lucky gave Sanchez wow I got hell I
had to help my partner with something so
I got caught up you know I get it I get
it hungover
no I I no man I was up late we're having
fun last last time last time and I'm
here whatever oh wow what happened
man I can't wait to take a show over on
Monday and possibly Tuesday
you gotta destroy me the entire time oh
no we're not going to talk about
politics we're going to talk about all
Tony it's just gonna be a Tony roast
two [__] hours well you'll have four
hours um including Texas fall on
Tuesdays oh that's right yeah I might
pop in on Tuesday I don't know okay all
right you want to hop into my show yeah
absolutely why not all right have you
already have you already started to
change the logo and [__] I know you're
going to do something it's gonna yeah
you'll see what happens I know I know
you're gonna do some something [__] up
hey I got your your um Pride design the
[__] that that they were requesting I
got it up on the store let me show you
let me see if I can do it up here and
that that where the [__] is it oh God
damn here it is okay here's here's the
uh the pride shirt I want to show you
because you told me you said just do
like black and white I was like ah
you're so vanilla God damn I mean you
could do whatever color you want I know
I did I did four so I did a blue shirt
and I did I did gray okay and then I did
I did your request black because I like
black shirts and then I did a white
shirt you know Black is Black is always
slimming you know right looks great
that's why I that's why I'm always in
Black oh I'm always in Black you know if
you see me uh on this show without a
black shirt that means I felt thin that
day probably that's probably what it is
I didn't need that thinning effect yeah
I mean honestly you could do whatever
you could do a pink one if you want you
know maybe throw a pink well I was going
to there was a yellow one but I I was
like no let's keep it simple yeah I
didn't want to I didn't want it to be as
simple as what you were saying right we
can always we can always We'll add
hoodies what stickers yeah do a bunch of
stuff coffee cups coffee cups be cool
yeah so we'll do a bunch of stuff with
the the new and and this is Gabe's
design he took the [__] logo and made
it um The Pride colors of the rainbow
which should really piss off star star
gal says we need ladies fitted tees
it's my friend okay sure all right I'll
see what I can do you know we got some
people were requesting tank tops because
it's summer too so I mean maybe we'll do
a gun right whatever you know well I
think we I think I've had a [__]
fanny pack before
um oh yeah we should put that on there
yeah we should put the pride one on a
fanny pack fanny pack has definitely
made a comeback the last few years yeah
sure now everyone's but people also
don't wear them around their waist they
put them over their shoulder like
they're like so it's not a fanny pack
because Fanny would indicate that you
put it on your ass right yeah yeah this
one is like a shoulder pack so what's
what what is it called when you put it
in the front
if it's not a fanny if it's not on your
fan I thought that's where a fanny pack
went what's a fanny man what's that I
know but that's someone said oh you got
a nice Fanny what would you yeah yeah
but that's around your waist and you
have the fantasy
yeah but why would you hold on why would
you expose the fanny pack like open
zipper area to the back of you
why wouldn't you put it listen listen
the rules here I'm just telling you what
the words are your fanny is your ass and
when you say fanny pack that wouldn't
indicate that the pack goes on your
fanny now I understand that people like
it doesn't make sense to have this thing
on my ass it makes more sense to have it
up front it's easier to act this right
get to my credit cards and my cell phone
and my Chapstick or whatever the hell
you're carrying maybe your weed whatever
you're carrying in your painting look
Tony look this is okay we're gonna pull
this up oh he's gonna [__] fact check
me here on the fanny pack thing look 12
simple ways to wear a fanny pack oh
Jesus
all right I'm I'm gonna show me which
one we're trying to talk puts it on your
ass we're trying to [__] have a
serious discussion here about fanny
packs show me which one yeah
wear your fanny pack around your waist
for a classic style right okay um sling
the bag across your chest for a more
modern style that's the one you're
talking about right okay what's this one
here let your fanny pack Stand Out by
layering it over here over your clothes
I've seen this before all right so it's
not it's like it's like a winner this is
like a winner style type Fanny yeah yeah
he's got it over your coat or something
all right wearing your fanny pack under
your jacket for a Chic look what yeah
why does this Chic I don't know I would
also say this is like the tourist secure
look like you know how like they're like
oh wear your passports under your shirt
kind of thing or that don't let any
anyone steal your [__] right put your
valuables in your locked fanny pack
underneath your jacket yeah right okay
all right um this is the same [__]
thing as the other one yeah how are
these different come on I don't know
about this one
now that now that we get into this list
I'm calling [__] on this list
because this is the list this list you
came up with this [__] thing is bogus
no this one is this one said it's at
Slinger sling your back across your
chest for a more modern style and this
one says use a solid color fanny pack
for casual outfits it's the same way
you're wearing it though yeah I don't
know yeah you're getting a different
fanny pack sure sure okay you can get
simple patterns here we go go for a
pattern fanny pack for fashion forward
looks is this a fanny pack or is this a
purse this is starting to get into purse
territory right it's a little bit bigger
I mean it's a fan it indicates a small
yeah that's a big Fanny that's back well
I mean you know I'm not gonna body shame
you when you got a big Fanny you got a
big fan you might have a small Fanny and
want a big fanny pack I don't know yeah
all right let's see number seven pick a
small fanny pack for more sophisticated
why the thumbs what the [__] is this
about okay your list is absolute garbage
I don't believe anything go to the next
one go to the next one I don't believe
anything this and watch with the what
the [__] is with this I don't know what
is this no I'm talking
there's a lot of shading what the hell
is going on there I don't know okay
Jesus Christ hey laid back fun look
slouchy fanny pack okay [__] what the
hell what what a slouchy slouchy what
the [__] your list is garbage okay
create what the [__] streetwear Vibe hey
man you said this is the ways yeah it
was the waves pack check these are also
other styles of fanny packs okay I'm
starting to doubt I'm starting to doubt
your uh your research capabilities here
I'm just saying okay number 10 get
fashion forward why the Fashion Board uh
uh language here it gives it because
it's forward on you and the Banny is
when it's supposed to be on your ass
behind you they're like no forward
fashion forward yeah with the fanny pack
over a dress how does this make it
wearing different just because it's just
because you got to dress on I I find
these I find this list totally [__]
um ridiculous what are you doing what
are you doing man are you reaching for
your
oh you know what I do have a fanny pack
but if you gotta own a fanny pack at
least for a prop right no I have I have
a God damn in this [__] out here I'll
just do this yeah do that
there you go whoa holy moly that's a lot
of life it's so bright okay there we go
that's better anyways you should do that
every day I should do that I should get
rid of this desk lamp
um no so there's a
uh what am I doing I was trying to get
this light working okay but the uh what
was I saying fanny pack you got a fanny
pack oh no yeah yeah I've got a I've got
a I've got a a prop a prop fanny pack
it's a lifeguard so it's a red one that
says lifeguard on it with a white cross
that's the only fan of pack I own and I
I never wear it though I'm kind of like
maybe I should wear it now maybe yeah
maybe you could try different styles
right you could try it over a dress or
you could try slouchy a streetwear style
maybe you could maybe you could do more
sophisticated look and get a smaller one
right and then and then if you wanted
you get a pattern fanny pack for a more
fashion forward right fashion forward
right or you can you know use a solid
color yeah for like casual outfits right
right so who knows maybe maybe we make a
fanny pack yeah and and look it's no
cost to us if people like it they can
buy it if they don't like it then we can
[__] say oh my God
how long did we spend on talking about
fanny packs when we got [__] to do oh
God all right let's get into it you
brought it up I know I know I just
wanted to make sure we we got the to the
bottom all I can say is though the
amount of nicknames that people are
given uh
uh given a fanny pack are pretty great
there's a mushroom pack there's a a
penis pack there's a a a a sack pack
sack Pack huh yeah like a snack pack but
with a snack hey did you know did you
know you got a dick in the background
huh you have a penis in the background
yeah there's a penis there's a penis
everyone always makes fun of the penis
Shadow and they think I should get rid
of it but I can't get rid of it now now
that you put it yeah the penis is that a
rhino is that a real Bush or is that a
fake Bush
on the penis is it a real Bush or a
vegan right there is that is that like a
real like a real plant what do you think
it is huh I don't know it's [__] fake
are you kidding me you think I water
other things so it's like it's like a
merkin yeah yeah and whatever yeah
okay have you ever heard of a Matt Walsh
before oh yeah oh my God okay so he's
complaining listen to this he says quote
in quotes what is a woman because he
still does not know what a woman is him
and Ben Shapiro both I know I can't
believe he traveled all around the world
made a [__] move and he still doesn't
know what a woman is he said what a warm
what is a woman was trending at number
four a moment moment ago
all right and has now disappeared from
the trending list completely it's gone
Gabe Sanchez the old regime
what is with them in the word regime
they've really long for a regime don't
they do they I mean do they know well no
they don't long they they don't long for
it they have a regime right right that
is true it's like Lauren bobert it's
like the you know when she was like
um
uh Biden's regime learned about politics
from Rachel Maddow and it's like first
off regime deals with like Authority
authoritarian tyrannical right people
overthrow government yeah people over
try to overthrow democracies and [__]
right but the idea that you're like wait
but wouldn't it be you got like it is I
mean that wouldn't be it is you guys
that are the regime and the fact also
it's like
you guys are [__] idiots the idea
that you're like oh like in his tweet
the old regime is back or whatever so so
you read so so now I even asked the
question in your uh retweet I was like
so is Matt Walsh saying that
Elon musk's Twitter
is removing the TR the topic the
trending time right well didn't didn't
they they liked Elon like last week
didn't they do you remember that yeah
when they love you they're like oh this
could be the greatest thing ever this is
going to save our country and save the
world because Elon bought Twitter and
he's gonna bring back Free Speech right
and Matt Walsh goes on to say here the
old regime blacklisted the trend which I
don't know if he knows what the word
blacklisted means but it doesn't really
apply to what he's saying you can type
it in like literally you can type in
what is a woman and it'll pull up the
tweets
also something to be said about that is
it it could be something that that
changed because uh Elon made sure that
you could do you know that you can't
type in and uh before I say this I want
to give context
um they're um in Twitter you can't type
it in no no so Ben is it Ben Collins is
that who it is for yeah the reporter
right yeah he's he's kind of he kind of
gets under elon's skin right you're
right and so he had he had a few tweets
that were exposing
um
I think it was like maybe a few weeks
ago where it's basically was like you
you could you can't now but you could
search for cats and blenders like dogs
in blenders oh remember that whole thing
that came up that Elon Musk was like oh
man this platform is totally I've ridden
this platform of all these things he's
like dude I could literally type in cats
and blenders and the videos are gross
and disgusting and terrible but you
allow them on a platform despite you
saying that this is a place where none
of that stuff happens and then what
happened is if you go into Twitter let
me see if I can still think but at one
point if you wanted Twitter
and typed they have now actively black
uh like banned or or a shadow band that
that uh if I type cats in blenders I
think what happens is I get a
oh okay they fixed it because what
happened was at one point if you typed
in the phrase cats and blenders or dogs
and blenders the thing that was you
could search for before what happened
was you would get an error on Twitter
that says like we can't search for this
for you
and so so Ben Collins did this where he
did a video and he's like look here's
all the data here's the screenshots
here's the receipts everything
and then Elon was like you can't do that
that's not a thing it's not available on
Twitter he's like dude again here are
the receipts do it yeah I mean so that's
the you know it's the [__] Elon Elon
gets all under their skin but when when
the when the question comes in from uh
Matt Walsh and he's like the old regime
the old regime what are you talking
about right you guys [__] clamored by
saying Elon Musk is in charge he [__]
and he fired everyone
right it's like and they said that was
the reason why it was going to be great
again make Twitter great Again by firing
everybody the old regime so he says uh
uh um again he's bitching here that what
was a woman which is his movie and they
really wanted this to Trend today June
1st because today's first day of pride
month the whole one is going to be a lot
of this right right what is a woman they
wanted it trending and they're really
[__] they're they're not coping well
when it doesn't Trend and it's probably
because Matt no one [__] gives a [__]
about your stupid [__] movie yeah
they just don't give a [__] they don't
care that's probably what it is but Ben
Shapiro you know you know you know who
Ben Shapiro is right yeah yeah yeah
super dry
what drives a room as soon as he wants
in I'm just saying the guy speaks the
words actually and then it's like
right [__] all the moisture just
somehow it's like it's like [__]
Moses part of the Dead Sea or the the
Red Sea and uh
and and just
gone no water gun no he just spoke the
words he was like
at all yeah done gone see I wanted to
say the word moist moist okay moist and
Ben Shapiro should not be in the same
sentence um but I just did it okay Ben
Shapiro's upset about this too and the
reason why is because Matt Walsh uh is
with the daily wire that Nazi rag that
Ben Shapiro runs yeah right which is the
same the same Nazi rag that Ben Shapiro
uh said
you know he criticized a bunch of
Republicans for being white supremacists
and Neo-Nazi he's like oh wow what where
do these guys come from and it's like
you mean the people that you [__]
right hand or two all right right you
mean your folks you know the ones you
now you're upset that right they're you
know okay they're saying the
anti-semitic stuff to you
okay so so Jeremy here
um was tweeting a thread and I'm not I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna read all the red
but he's like Twitter cancel the deal
with at real daily wire to Premiere what
is a woman for free on the platform
because two instances of misgendering
I'm not kidding okay here's the thing if
you have to sell your [__] movie for
free on Twitter your movie [__] sucks
I mean that's not the first time
remember the other one that the the
Prairie movie that they made oh yeah
daily one with uh what's her what's her
face the one from Star Wars yeah
I have [__] bigot what's your name
Cara yes yeah uh well she's irrelevant I
guess if the if us not knowing who she
is proves dude no no no no yeah carrot
Dune is it no I don't know yeah yeah and
then no no no no that's her [__] no
that's Gina Carano Gina yeah
is the character she played on the
Mandalorian exactly her character name
is more relevant than she is yeah okay
so Ben Shapiro here because they failed
on that movie and what what is a woman
failed so [__] hard at face planning
because people like wait you don't know
what a woman is you had to travel all
around the world and talk to all kinds
of people to figure out what a woman is
shouldn't you know what a woman is by
them
um but they did it they did this movie
and it sucked so bad that they wanted to
give it away for free on a platform
where you can watch it for free where
it's free to have an account yeah and
Ben Shapiro's response here is this
Behavior by my Twitter corporate
directly opposes Elon Musk commitment to
free speech and I sincerely hope he does
something about it now what they're
blaming here that well the right is
blaming their new CEO they're saying
she's the one that who is but she's not
even the CEO no Gabe yay hey enough of
your [__] facts okay
enough of your back it's so weird where
they're like oh the old regime it where
there is no regime he fired them all
they're 80 of that regime is gone right
not only are they gone they now work at
companies and very successful one of the
people from the old regime stayed on
until the Ron DeSantis uh [__] face
just plant right
um it left a day later he's like it has
nothing to do with this even though he
was the head of growth and was in charge
of Twitter spaces wait he was in charge
of growth
yeah he was the head of head of growth
at Twitter uh and so no wonder no wonder
he kept Elon kept him as part of the old
regime he's like oh you're stupid you
can stay
you're worthless and really bad at your
job you you can stay yeah I mean you
know but it's really weird that they're
like the old regime right they're gonna
blame it on the old regime which there
is none yeah and then they're like the
new regime though like yeah but there
isn't a new version we want a regime
current old new we want regime because
we're authoritarians right it's a really
[__] weird stuff man this projection
that they have a lot of a lot of cell
phones man let me tell you yeah well I
showed the clip earlier of Mark Wayne Uh
from Oklahoma where they were [__]
laughing at him in this hearing did you
see the reality one huh yeah oh [__] it
I mean he couldn't have [__] picked
out the biggest rake and threw it in
front of him and stepped on it oh man I
don't want to talk about reality it's
like okay care about reality I'm not I'm
not concerned with real yeah no [__]
you're like I'm thank you for saying the
quiet part all that like we already knew
that you guys weren't living in reality
but the fact that you're honestly
outwardly telling us right now no I
don't want to I don't want to deal in
reality or I don't want to live in
reality or whatever he said it's like oh
man you guys just one step like [__]
one step after another you Chuck
Grassley earlier this morning oh my God
I played that clip so let's talk about
that for a second but let's not talk
about the grass League where he's like
oh well I mean there's it's just
accusations is nothing really it's a
[__] lie but and we really can't
investigate it to where uh I mean there
would be any accusations on anything it
just uh we want to make sure Chris Ray
this is this is the point about Trump
who was approved by Me by the way
cracker actually voted for Christopher
Ray to be the FBI director I don't know
if you know that but I me tracker Ashley
wanted him to be the FBI director under
Trump these stupid [__] right man I
can't I can't tell you now the story
though is that Rudy how does what what
is this Rudy thing okay so smell what
Rudy's stepping in here yeah yeah well
it's a big pile of [__] so this whole I
this whole time that Republicans like
Comer and Jim Jordan like we got this
document and it eludes to all this stuff
that uh vice president and then Vice
President Biden did at the time it's the
real thing that's going to crack this
case open well it turns out that that
document was given to the doj by none
other than Rudy kaluti Giuliani surely
it can't be made up right surely it's
it's not something that's given to them
right you know Rudy Giuliani happened to
have this document he also happened to
have the guy this is wait this is the
guy who who went over overseas they
[__] they this is what Leb parnan's
claims yeah let Parnes claims that they
[__] bought Hunter Biden hookers and
drugs and they took his laptop made a
[__] copy of it and then got it back
into the United States and planted it in
that [__] repair store so Rudy
Giuliani could go commandeering not only
not only in that repair shop but give it
to a repair shop that was owned by a
blind computer repair technician and
somehow that guy knew that this computer
was most definitely
Hunter Biden's now the question is like
did Hunter Biden actually drop it off or
did somebody sign for it to drop it off
and then Rudy Giuliani was then tipped
off by someone from I think it was like
what did Lev say in Kazakhstan or
something like that is where he was I
don't remember we should try I've tried
to get I'm trying to message well he was
on he was on he was on a Twitter space
yesterday with the uh krasins with Ed or
Brian maybe I should definitely they had
their own space right and it was like
it's like two hours I wouldn't spoke in
one of them one day because someone was
telling [__] lines so I had to go
break up the lines
um in in the style and form that I do
and you know throw torches but anyways
uh in in the krakenstein's um space I
just want to address one thing so yeah
uh Giselle says he uses Braille tools
that's right I mean that's blind people
read with Braille but it's it's not like
how could he
what I'm trying to say is it's not like
oh how would he know or whatever the
question is
Rudy Giuliani knew about the computer
before it ended up at the computer store
and then the computer store technician
knew to contact Rudy Giuliani right
there's a lot of these details that
don't make a lot of sense and they don't
add up so it's not that like well they
do add me they they do add up well yeah
okay okay
it adds up to them [__] making this
[__] up right and and because here's the
thing is because they got the copy of
Hunter Biden's lamped up now uh some of
this webs talked about again we should
have him on the show to talk to him
about this yeah give the audience his
well he follows me now so I should reach
out to him ah yeah reach out to him see
if we can see if we can get him hey we
make him on oh he was on he was on
Michael Cohen's podcast the other day
yeah yeah well again probably come on
here yeah um and tell a story you know
he's not scared to say it I've heard him
say it in these spaces and even when
he's challenged he's not scared to say
it but basically what what he what he
claims is that when they got the laptop
it really didn't have the [__] on it
that they wanted so they to cook it and
then they had to make sure that it got
in Rudy giuliani's hands and because
Rudy is the inlet to the FBI just like
this [__] document where he's passing
off [__] information and they're
making it oh well this is evidence this
is we got to investigate this even
though it's [__] and they do FBI FBI
investigates all kinds of stuff all the
time they investigate [__] that's true
they investigate [__] [__] that takes
them nowhere
because it's just it's just not real it
just doesn't it's not a thing that that
leads them to a conclusion of a crime
they investigate [__] all the time now
the idea that somehow and and this is I
understand what they were trying to do
what they are trying to do is paint this
picture that Hunter Biden's laptop broke
after a long night of hookers and
cocaine right like he got the cocaine on
the [__] laptop and it was stuck in
the [__] keys or something maybe
there was all kinds of stuff that was
flying around I got on a laptop you
needed it cleaned or something and he
took it into this repair shop like
Hunter mine just pick out some [__]
random repair shop to take his laptop to
and he would take it in there and this
and this this blind repairman would be
like oh man oh man look this is oh
there's crime on this I should contact
Rudy Giuliani like what the [__] how are
you people not putting this [__]
together yeah that yeah there's no
there's no way that a guy
who works in a computer repair shop
in Delaware would know whether or not
like because the other thing to do is
like oh how did he know how does he know
if oh God Mr says semen Aid
uh like it could be it could be he got
seminate on the keyboard that could be
possibly could have went to Chick-fil-A
and ordered one of them Frozen cement
AIDS yeah well not only that always the
audience always a [__] seeming
according to Danny or uh Joey Moreno
Jody manarino he's so manly he has two
ends in manorino yeah um
but it's one of those things where
you're like you know again how would the
repair technician a blind computer
repairman no
that Hunter Biden was the real person
who dropped it off right right verify
the id'd no typically what happens is
you come in and you're like great here's
my credit card or some cash payment as a
deposit
you know I signed the the document and
then you tell me when to come back
and then at some point because there was
no response of supposedly to Hunter
Biden he then thought well you know what
the person I should be contacting is
Rudy Giuliani because I know Rudy
Giuliani has been somehow searching for
this laptop that nobody else knew about
right and that he should be the one to
give it to the FBI and he somehow just
pulled Rudy giuliani's personal cell
phone number right out of his life it's
when you're like oh well you know he he
clearly was Hunter Biden it's like
whether or not Hunter Biden actually
dropped his computer off how would he
would have like how would he have known
that Rudy was the first Contact in the
book also again how did he contact him
right like who did he reach out to was
it uh was it what's her face that uh
that worked with him and is now suing
him I don't know but like they had a
contact and he knew who to contact well
you know typically to get rid of
Giuliani let's get let's see if you can
get uh lib on see if you can message him
since since you follow each other
probably go up in the DMS you'll he'll
he'll get it more Stevie wants to come
on the show and um we'll see if we can
get him on and just tell his story
because it's and again this is what he
alleges right yeah because Leb was with
the detail I don't so according to Chris
Derrickson in the chat he says I live in
Delaware repairman claimed the laptop
after 90 days Delaware law says you
can't take it until a year after it's
been abandoned yes and I think that's
true and I and the laptop repair guy is
the one he's gonna take some of the Fall
here for these [__] boneheads because
they convinced this guy to do this stuff
and this guy not only is gonna get
damaged hard with defamation because
he's lied and lied in line and it's been
proven to be lying that this [__] just
isn't what they say it is
um but Rudy Rudy decides that he's going
to try this tactic with this document
about Jill Biden apparently and I don't
don't think this is gonna go the way
that they think it's going to go now
that everyone found out that the
Whistleblower or the document or
whatever the [__] this is is from Rudy
Giuliani as if you can trust anything
that [__] I mean this is the
same some [__] that went to the Arizona
speaker of the house at the time in 2020
to be like yeah you need to overturn the
election I have the evidence and he's
like where is he like I don't know I
mean it's not really evidence evidence
it's like you know like if if if they
were going to steal the election and
there was some stupid theory on how they
would do it then that's right I mean we
wrote that on a napkin and then I'm
gonna give it to you and you're gonna
read it and then you'll know that this
is how it could not be stolen if you
wanted to some alternatively and not
only that but like I see people in the
chat that are saying it's not his laptop
right like we don't know if it's
actually laptop most likely no no it's
most likely it's not his laptop now I'm
not saying that certain photos that they
have that they hacked or took right now
right and that could be the [__] that
they lifted in in Lev's allegation
because Lev is saying his account of it
is that they had
um Hunter Biden and uh prostitutes they
gave him drugs and they bought him
prostitutes and got him in a room and
got him destroyed I mean man if you're
doing coke and you got some you know
good looking prostitutes I'm sure you're
going to be distracted for a little bit
right I mean yeah that's the thing a
guy's gonna do probably right especially
like Hunter Biden especially yeah I mean
especially if someone is uh uh is either
a sex addict or a drug addict right like
you're you're playing into the vices so
you're like it doesn't take a lot of I
mean they're trying to destroy it right
they're trying to distract him and
they're hanging the carrot in front of
him that's you know caked in cocaine and
stuck somewhere in a prostitute but the
point is this the point is this is that
um Ledges that they distracted him and
got a copy of his hard drive right now
that doesn't mean the hard drive that
they're claiming is this hard drive is a
hard drive they may have just pulled
[__] they were like oh well this [__]
sucks this guy just takes dick pics what
the hell what's this that's the thing
right
they've taken they could have taken a
they could have copied over the laptop
and like oh everything on here is a
bunch of dick pics and pretty pigs and
drugs and all this stuff so you know
what did they expect
what did they expect when they're like
you know what the best way the best way
to distract this guy is blowing hookers
what did they expect to see on this
laptop besides a bunch of pictures of
him doing blow and hookers like what the
[__] what the [__] did they expect it's
one of those it's one of those things
where you're like
you I mean you know it doesn't take a it
doesn't take a lot of mental capacity
for for Maga to believe anything that
comes out of anything no [__] you don't
see the Republican yeah I know the
Republican party's mouth but like with
this they're like look we have this
laptop that's a copy of a hard drive
from a laptop that was owned by Hunter
Biden and also we put some other things
on this computer so when you look at it
you say oh yeah look there's all these
photos and then there's all these
documents so everything on here must be
his right
it's the it's the way that they look at
logic and they're like well if this is
true then everything else is true too
and it's like right that's not right how
that works right well I mean you know
they're [__] Androids and Bots right
that's what they are they're magabots
but I mean yeah it but you know
Republicans don't want to despite the
fact that Lev Parnes was
deep within the Trump Giuliani Maga you
know umbrella
Republicans don't want to uh you could
even say that Lev is a whistleblower
right because he's like look I always
hit these places and this is I'm not
gonna I don't have to hide myself I'm
going to come out and say that the
people that were involved did drug them
did give them prostitutes they copied
the hard drive they put it on your
computer I was around for this stuff I
was around for that stuff like
unless there's something privy that he
can't say because of whatever a deal has
been made he's gonna say it and
Republicans don't like the fact that a
former Maga Trump right I is is coming
out with these Revelations well the
other thing that they don't like and
they go after him in these spaces and
like oh well you you took a plea deal
he's like no I didn't I went all the way
they a [__] jury convicted me and
they sentenced me and I served my time I
can't flip there's nothing to flip I'm
not flipping on anything I I went to
court they found me guilty of the crimes
that I committed and I went to prison
for It Dummy there's no there I can't
I'm not flipping for anything I'm just
telling the truth now now that I know
the [__] truth because he admits that
he's like I was duped a little bit right
now rather that's true or not rather
lives you know capacity was that he was
being duped or he knew the truth at the
time speaking of someone who tries to
dupe people have you seen this Android
that's running around Iowa oh my God
this is [__] weird dude okay you guys
thought the ha ha ha ha what's weird or
you thought that when he went in a
restaurant like hi my name's Tim okay if
you thought those were weird well you
got something coming because this guy
this skin suit this fascist alien in the
skin suit is walking around Iowa taking
weird ass selfies with people watch this
and then he gets mad at reporters when
they ask him questions I guess he's
really mad at him lunch why not take any
questions from voters
okay so people are coming up will be
talking to me whatever they want to talk
to me about
dude why so [__] agitated bro God
damn it you've got someone who's coming
up to you as a reporter to be like
you're not talking to you're not talking
to voters why are you talking them
because he can't [__] talk to voters
he doesn't know how to talk in general
he can barely get by without someone
saying something he goes haha okay okay
like Android [__] glitching out here
there's a reason why they're not letting
him do that it's because we're all
[__] goofing on him every time he
does and now he's now Christina push I
was like Hey limit the interactions to
photos only don't talk to anyone oh
photos only well if this is the weird
ass photos that he's taking watch this
I'm gonna turn the sound off and you
tell me if this looks weird or not
uh
um kind of awkward yeah weird Smiles got
a lot of photos okay
[Music]
also like does he think that he's gonna
be as like mean and ruthless As Trump or
he's like what are you blind what are
you blind I would laugh if the guy was
like actually I am you know what this is
I am the Blind repair man from The
Creator shop right how dare you shame me
ah here's here's the thing is that
DeSantis is not gonna attack Trump like
Trump's gonna attack him holy [__] we
were talking about this morning in text
Trump is absolutely eviscerating him
just [__] burning him to the ground
on true social now I you know folks I
know you don't want to hear this and I
know this is probably going to piss a
lot of people off but I can't wait for
Trump to come back to Twitter I can't
[__] wait I can't [__] wait the
the a level attacks that he will that he
will [__] pile on top of Rhonda
santis Chris Christie and Mike Pence and
destroy those [__] absolutely
destroy their careers while he's being
federally indicted wow he's got 34
felony counts in New York and everyone's
gonna be like on the right it's gonna be
like yeah woohoo let's make him our
nominee he'll lose again like yeah okay
go ahead that's fine you know what you
keep doing you buddy like or or just
like the fact that the Republican party
you know they they love to back a loser
right regardless if they go with uh
Chris Christie which they'll never do
they go with Mike Pence which they'll
never do uh they'll go with Ron DeSantis
which they'll never do and really I mean
the only person left that because all of
these people except Tim Scott which who
knows if Tim Scott actually has any sort
of possibility of a chance I don't know
I'm saying I'm saying yeah if you wait
wait you think I'm being serious here do
you think because the Iowa straw poll is
going to eliminate a lot of these
[__] yeah yeah yeah but do you
think in the Iowa straw poll that Tim
Scott will get more votes than Nikki
Haley
no okay and Nikki Haley Nikki hey do you
think Nikki Haley breaks five percent in
the straw poll
no I think she's okay so Tim Scott's
done Nick Haley's done because I'm I'm
telling you I'm telling you Trump is
back is gonna get something low
percentage wow yeah but Vivek no no but
but the only the only reason that he is
attacking uh or has attacked he hasn't
really gone after Nikki Haley recently
that I know of it was when she initially
launched because it was everyone uh
people are asking if I'm on a sync yeah
I'm out of sync I gotta hold on let me
hold on let me leave and come back
almost done
we are almost done
she was the only one that came out on
the on the campaign Trail it was the
first one and the immediate [__]
disqualifier was the fact that she said
I won't run if Trump is running
right that already kicked her out
because she's now a hypocrite and she
took she took her words back right so
then you've got uh vivec which we know
we've agreed he's a plant he's just
there to mix things up and draw the
votes away and then give him back to
Trump yep then you've got Tim Scott
which again is a person that nobody
knows a lot about but supposedly he's a
46 year old virgin nothing wrong with
that whoa whoa but also he spends a lot
of time you don't just get to Breeze
over that with me are you kidding me you
haven't heard this no I already I
already was supposedly you know he's a
force there's nothing wrong with that
but you know when you're going after
people there's this there's this thing
Scott is 46. yeah he's 46. he's the one
that's way older than that right yeah
and someone can confirm this I'm pretty
sure he's 46 but also uh this holders is
still there's this narrative that he's a
46 year old virgin then there's also uh
the fact that no one knows that uh okay
Tim Scott is older he's in his 50s
he's got to be one he's got to be in his
50s
he has to be um we're gonna go along
here to smoke out this 46 year old
version okay he's 57. see now let me
hold on wait he's a 57 year old virgin
you're telling me this guy's never had
sex
hmm is that what you're saying in 2000
that's what virgin means yeah yeah you
know why I said that it's because when
he came out
came out well yeah as a virgin well yeah
yeah so do you come out as a version the
reason I said 46 was because the story
came out 11 years ago oh so when he was
46 he's like I'm a virgin so is he still
a virgin it goes after 16 years in
public life and winning a seat in the
U.S house this is back in 2012. Scott
Now 46 and still unmarried and oh admits
that he's no longer a version virgin
okay that's what it was at the age of 46
he finally had sex that is what happened
Kevin says YouTube 57 year old
masturbator
hey man I'm eventually one of these days
I hope to be 57 and I'm probably gonna
be waxing the old carrot at 57 I would
imagine so I mean you know basically
just bet that's what that's what he
admitted to at the point
um
because according to this article it
said let me just make sure like age of
46 after 16 years in public life because
he entered
yeah the Evangelical Christian who
entered public Life as a 30 year old
virgin admits he's no longer no longer
virgin after 16 years which means he was
a 46 year old virgin when he finally
Jesus Christ
some people are saying some people are
saying I'm not saying this some people
are saying like Harry here uh nothing
wrong with that right he could be that
yeah all right fine with it I'm fine
with that I'm fine with him Lindsey
Graham and whoever else wants there are
people that say that Tim Scott said he
spends a lot of time with Lindsey Graham
now if that's true and there's something
there again nothing wrong hey yeah but
obviously that would be like a double
wow though for them that is kind of I
don't know is there a I mean there may
be a law in South Carolina that the two
senators can't be schlubbing I mean
I don't know what they're up to I don't
know I don't know this committee would
think of that it's one of those things
where they're like
oh he's not white and they're gay oh
that's a big No-No right right they're
like can't do that so now whatever
floats their boat if Lindsay lady G and
Tim Scott wanna you know want to have a
nice Saturday night together I'm not
opposed to that whatever they want to do
whatever whatever that's right don't be
[__] demonizing the people that want
to do the same thing right you [__]
don't you know it's to each their own
whatever people want to do you know
assuming it's legal uh then go for it
but
Tim Scott is someone that we know very
little about hmm right well you know
what we may learn more we may learn and
that's the that's the thing and I think
Tim Scott is going to regret that
happening I think people are gonna
assuming he doesn't stay around past the
straw poll or it goes in oh what's the
next one South Carolina is in New
Hampshire
and then New Hampshire oh I mean so well
I mean they do the straw poll in Iowa
but a lot of times in the straw poll in
Iowa if you can't even get recognized
you're not gonna you're not even gonna
right get in the cool place which means
you don't have a chance in hell if he
gets it yeah yeah and I don't think he
has a chance but if he does get into New
Hampshire and there's some weird reason
that he's stuck around right Donald
Trump doesn't seem as a threat he he
welcomed him into I mean maybe
racist but even though he is a racist uh
uh I don't know of him walking him
welcome me and him in was because he was
like uh oh I don't see him as a threat
and that's honestly what I think I think
he doesn't see Tim Scott as a threat so
he was like oh yeah yeah come on in like
welcome to the party I wish you the best
of luck everyone else Mike Pence uh uh
Nikki Haley
um
also uh
uh wow uh uh Rhonda santis like yeah I
mean it's hard to remember these [__]
I know I know these are all people that
he actually feels threatened by vivec
obviously not because they're in cahoots
right right and doesn't have a chance
right all right he's paid not to have a
chance Christy obviously that's another
one we'll see uh Edward points out I'm
imagining Scott and Graham having
news Max and chill I think that's I
don't know that's the same as Netflix
and chill but it may be
um speaking of Iowa yeah uh someone
showed up in Iowa in a in a skin suit
um which is just as awkward as Ron the
Sanctus as he would call him but I mean
man I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you this is
a lackluster kind of crowd I'm just
gonna say it this guy can't draw [__]
flies really at this point but but this
guy's gonna win that's the craziest part
he's gonna [__] win watch this here's
here's a cheetah dust unit in Iowa
apparently yesterday shaking hands with
three evil
nice to meet you
he can go one by one because there's
just a handful right where is he he's in
Iowa that's what they said
is that the first time is this the first
time he's been back in Iowa since
running away from the storm I don't I'm
sure but look at this did he just like
did he just like pull over the side and
run like hey there's an office building
what he's like there's got to be people
in there yeah let's see if there's well
I can't get a crowd anywhere else let's
see if there's like four or five people
in there that'll shake my hand and the
other thing too is like whoever I wonder
who was taking the video right like
either oh this is Dan scavino Shirley
right yeah yeah and they're like oh man
look at this turnout and you're like
dude this is not what I think it is man
this is pretty bad right like if you
were like you know regardless of of Ron
DeSantis being unable to have any sort
of normal interaction with any person
if you were to compare the two videos
like yeah he's not handling the pressure
so great but at least the turnouts there
this one's like oh well you you did you
got less than 10 people so
congrats you know there's one two three
four five six seven seven yeah that's
that's pretty good crap right for
someone who's running for president I
mean just shy of a decade you know right
[__] me this is so pathetic oh and we're
gonna stay right on top of them as they
get more and more pathetic it's gonna be
great I can't believe that guy is gonna
win
yeah that's the best part if there was
ever like I there are moments when I'm
like ah I wish I lived in one of these
states where the primaries happened so I
could attend and have an interaction
because I live all the way in [__]
the West Coast no one ever comes out
here yeah well you know it happens it is
California oh baby we're gonna stay on
top of them I'm sure there'll be plenty
of Clips tomorrow to show you these
boneheads hey speaking of boneheads
guess what today is today's Thursday so
that makes tomorrow Friday that's Friday
comes after Thursday Did you know that I
did not know that and on Friday in the
second hour of the show we go through
bone of the week where you vote you
decide for bone end of the week and we
break it down for you every single
Friday me and my co-host Gabe Sanchez on
YouTube so don't forget to vote on
YouTube just subscribe to the channel
you go to the community tab you'll vote
there this evening the other place you
can vote Gabe is on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod you can vote there
on Twitter app for bonehead of the week
and you can watch it tomorrow live on
Facebook if you'd like at the Tony
Michaels just go follow us on Facebook
at the Tony Michaels you can also watch
it on Twitch so follow us on Twitch we
want to thank everyone on Twitch for
giving us huge Support over there not
just for the follows but how you've been
linking your Prime account to your
Twitch account and giving us that one
free subscription you get with your
Amazon Prime account super important
helps us out and it's free for you to
give us monetary support so go to the
Tony michaels.com the instructions are
right there or the write down in the
description somewhere here just go down
there and click on how to link them
and mighty librarian are great one of
our great moderators gave you full
instructions she researched this gave
full instructions on how to do this so
it's very easy so thank you very much
for all the support there
oh boy I don't know what do you think
you think there's going to be bigger
news tomorrow about
um these uh documents now that um I it
seems like Espionage in these charges I
really I don't know Friday man Friday
when was the Corcoran news Monday yeah
and then we got this yesterday which was
um yeah I feel like there's more audio
games
um my Monday was Corcoran was Tuesday
the maintenance guy yep yeah this week
yeah something's got to come out
tomorrow yesterday well today tomorrow
it'll probably yeah it'll probably
bombshell so stay tuned don't miss a
single episode right here on the Tony
Michaels podcast Monday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
for two full hours on YouTube Twitter
twitch and Facebook same time same place
tomorrow bonehead of the week Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em
[Music]
IL born head ass Beacon